THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WILL HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT AT THEIR
CONVENTION IN MILWAUKEE.
GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
AUTHOR MARK STEYN JOINS US.
MARK, YOU WATCHED LAST NIGHT.
SO MANY LEVELS OF AWFULNESS.
BUT HOW WOULD YOU ASSESS WHAT
YOU SAW?
>> WELL, I THINK THE BEST
EXPLANATION FOR BLOOMBERG IS
THAT HE IS IN FACT A RUSSIAN
ASSET WHO HAS BEEN PLANTED INTO
THE DEMOCRAT RACE TO MAKE JOE
BIDEN LOOK FORCEFUL AND
VIGOROUS.
YOU’VE SAID THAT HE SPENT $460
MILLION TO WIND UP ON STAGE,
TALKING ABOUT NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS.
I UNDERSTAND, BY THE WAY, THAT
SINCE THE DEBATE, HE’S ASKED
EVERYONE THAT WATCHED THE DEBATE
TO SIGN A NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS.
SO HOPEFULLY -- THAT’S ANOTHER
FORM OF $60 BILLION DOLLARS.
YOU HAVE TO HAND TO IT THE
CHEROKEE DOMINATRIX.
SHE WON’T BE THE CANDIDATE BUT
SHE UTTERED THAT PHRASE,
HORSE-FACED LESBIANS, WHICH
HASN’T BEEN USED IN A
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE SINCE GROVER
CLEVELAND.
BUT TO FILLET HIM FOR CALLING
WOMEN HORSE-FACED LESBIANS AND
HE STOOD THERE LOOKING
HORSE-FACED HIMSELF, UNABLE TO
RESPOND TO IT.
THEN SHE STARTS GOING ON ABOUT
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS.
HE WON’T DISCLOSE HOW MANY
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS HE
SIGNED.
EVENTUALLY, IT’S SUCH A LIVELY
DEBATE, MIRACLE OF MIRACLES JOE
BIDEN WAKES UP AND HAS A SWING.
LIKE COME ON, MAN.
GOD LOVE YOU, MAN.
NDA, MAN.
I PLAYED FOR THE NDA YEARS AGO.
MY SON OWNS AN NDA FRANCHISE,
CHINESE GENERALS.
HE’S -- BLOOMBERG IS THE BIGGEST
DISASTER.
IF IT IS BILLIONAIRE TO
BILLIONAIRE, SENCICAL PEOPLE --
LIONEL SHRIVER, BEST SELLING
NOVELIST.
SHE SAID PEOPLE WILL WELCOME
BLOOMBERG AS A RESPITE FROM
TRUMP.
NO, THEY WON’T.
IF IT’S BILLIONAIRE TO
BILLIONAIRE, NOBODY -- PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO GO WITH THE
BILLIONAIRE WHO ISN’T LIKE THIS
GUY.
THE ONE THING YOU SAY ABOUT
TRUMP, WHEN HE CAME UP WITH THAT
ROSY O’DONNELL LINE, HE WASN’T
THE CREATURE OF MINDERS.
HE WASN’T THE CREATURE OF PEOPLE
THAT DON’T TEAR TELL THE SULTAN
THAT HE’S GOING TO HAVE TO COME
UP WITH AN EXPLANATION AS TO WHY
SO MANY OF THE GIRLS IN THE
HAREM HAD THE SIGN NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS.
IT WAS PATHETIC.
>> Tucker: PROBABLY THE BEST
SUMMARY I’VE HEARD OF AMERICAN
POLITICS.
I DON’T THINK YOU CAN BEAT
PRESIDENTS AND WE’RE ALL GOING
TO SUFFER.